it has been a bruisin weekend for
Michael Gove plagued by demons of two
decades ago yes it was a crime it was a
mistake I deeply regret it should you
have gone to prison well I was I was
fortunate in that I didn't but I do
think that it was a profound mistake and
I've seen the damage that drugs do
twisting the knife the Mail on Sunday
reprinted an article Mr Gove wrote for
The Times in 1999 in which he criticized
middle-class drug users who he said
wanted cocaine legalized Sajid Javid a
leadership hopeful while not naming Mr
Gove was scathing nevertheless there are
people that you know they they have
their organic food they boast about
buying Fairtrade they talk about climate
change and at the same time you come
Friday or Saturday night they're all in
Class A drugs this could all begin to
snowball for Mr Gove during any visits
to the United States for example he
should have declared past drug use on
the visa waiver program called Esther
Erin Hanlon is a u.s. immigration lawyer
how does the US government view
admissions of drug use they view that as
if it were a conviction for possession
how difficult is it gonna be for Mr Gove
now if he wants to travel to the United
States if he wants to travel to the US
now he is no longer able to use the visa
waiver program he will definitely need a
visa from this point forward and he will
have to disclose his prior drug use as
well as why he misrepresented himself on
the form if he actually ticked no to
that question Michael gobs campaign team
told Sky News they were satisfied he'd
filled out the forms correctly the
environment secretaries admissions have
provoked questions about not only the
strength of his leadership campaign but
of his character too whilst elsewhere it
has been a good day for the front-runner
Boris Johnson who despite appearing to
be reluctant to appear on camera
anywhere is still garnered the support
of some high-profile backers significant
support from arch brexit ear Steve Baker
who says Boris is the man to lead
Britain out of the EU while James
cleverly wants a leadership hopeful now
a Boris man I've seen him reach out
to audiences and voters that the
Conservative Party would not normally
expect to be on site and I know he can
run a successful executive operation
because I was part of the team that did
that when we were in London for eight
years so that's why I'm gonna be
supporting him for leader tomorrow the
race begins and only two candidates can
emerge eventually to fight it out for
the top job Nick Martin Sky News
Westminster